talk about the ultimate breakup Europe
and Africa have been splitting apart
from the American continents for
millions of years at a rate of
approximately 2.5 centimeters per year
the continents are moving about as fast
as our fingernails grow and as they
continue to split the rift between them
otherwise known as the Atlantic Ocean
will get even wider and all this drama
is leaving behind a major scar an
underwater valley called the
mid-atlantic ridge which tears more and
more as the continents slowly move apart
looking back on the Continental
relationship puts us a mere 300 million
years ago when Africa Europe the
Americas and all the other continents
from one big landmass the famous
supercontinent Pangea
due to the constant churning of magma
underneath the Earth's crust they all
split up and move to their modern-day
positions but it's destiny in the form
of magma and tectonic plates has
anything to say about it the continents
might have a chance of getting back
together but how will these stubborn
continents kiss and make up
scientists believe the plates will shift
causing the continents to rearrange and
get sacked together but in true tectonic
plate style it'll take about 250 million
years our planet has a violent soul
majestic and often destructive volcanic
explosions rattle our collective
imagination